to quote former president george w bush
fool me once
shame on you fool me twice uh uh the
point is
you're not gonna fool me again that was
his variation on a theme
we locked down for what eight months
nine months
then the virus was supposed to be going
away we
flattened the curve everything was
getting better we had these multiple
vaccines
and now the politicians want
to shut us down again some people have
had enough
one michigan business owner has has so
given up on these politicians that he
interrupted a local newscast
to get his message out for what he
thinks the american people should be
doing
the details on why the judge said no
is everything okay okay my government
leaders have abandoned me
are you are you the owners of four
trillion dollars of
stimulus money and gave it to who
special interest groups and campaign
donors i'm dave morris i own the place
so what's going on what's going on you
know what's going on tell me you tell me
hey we got a government that has taken
the stimulus money
they gave it to special campaign donors
they gave it to special interest
they abandoned me and they had put me in
a position where
i have to fight back okay so do you feel
that this is the right thing to do
absolutely i feel everybody needs to
stand up hey listen
there was enough money to give every
family every family in this country
twenty thousand dollars to go home for
two months
they chose to give it to special
interests and campaign donors
the kennedy space center and they
abandoned us
so you could have given me money i'd
gladly walk away for 60 days and let
this virus settle down
i'm not going to do it alone okay are
you going to continue to violate the
state's orders and stay open
state order this isn't an order this is
a conspiracy this is a tyranny
what do you want to tell other
restaurant owners who wake up stand up
this is america be free
dave morris michigan business owner more
american than just about anybody in this
country
certainly more american than the elected
people who are trying to shut us down
again wake up stand up be free
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
welcome back to our first friday show
we are now five days a week and we're
very excited because we're gonna be
going to radio as well
starting in january so we're just
getting in the spirit of things
i know ben shapiro was very upset that
i'm getting a fifth show
but it does mean i'm doing 25 more work
so it's a good time to be doing it
anyway because so much is going on
especially
with the presidential race there are
people who tell you this is absolutely
over and trump's got to concede right
now and that is simply not
the case my favorite comment from
yesterday is from old schooled
who says biden says built back better
biden also says that he's going to
appoint all the same shriveled up
cronies who destroyed things the first
time
this is true this is the point what
build back better which is this creepy
phrase that now all of the
establishmentarians all around the west
or reciting all around the world really
are reciting
is a a way to put back into place
the liberal world order the liberal
establishment
that president trump threw out of whack
for a few years
and they struck back and they tried to
one spy on him in 2016
then they tried to overturn that
election through the bureaucracy now it
seems there's a lot of shenanigans in
2020.
what it means is a reassertion of the
global or it's called globalism or
globalization
this liberal empire that takes
power away from people takes sovereignty
away from nations
takes the constitutional order away from
our
day-to-day living and replaces it with
bureaucratic technocracy build back
better it's the same thing that they've
been foisting on us for decades
and the question is are we going to
stand up to it
you know they want to they want to lock
you indoors they want to make sure that
you
you can never leave they actually do
they now want to prevent you
from going outside my friend nick circe
in
la the international film and television
star nick cersei
just the other day posted a video where
he said i'm on an illegal walk they
don't want me to go outside
well if you want to get outside i would
highly recommend rad power bikes
whether you want a new way to get around
town or out in nature even with the kids
in tow
you've got to get rad power bikes a
cross between a traditional bike and a
moped
but here's the key unlike a moped does
not require a special
driver's license you can go up to 20
miles per hour without
pedaling so you can get out and about
without getting sweaty rad power bikes
are affordable most e-bikes are in the 3
000 range rad power bikes start at just
999 and most are under 1500 bucks
if you have questions this is truly
shocking in this day and age
rad power bikes has dedicated us-based
customer support
they're there for you when you need them
makes the perfect gift for someone who
loves being active
and outdoors i'm so pleased that i can
get outdoors a little a little
bit more now especially that i'm in
tennessee and things aren't quite
as locked down but it's a great way to
get out great way to commute and a great
way to go out and have
some fun for a limited time rad power
bikes is offering flexible financing for
as low as zero percent apr plus free
shipping
bikes are going super fast make sure you
get your order in right away
you do that by texting knolls k o w l e
s to sixty four thousand
you'll get free shipping text knowles
canada wlas to sixty four thousand what
is that
name knowles to 64 000.
the people mandating the lockdowns do
not believe that the lockdowns are
necessary
for one's health and they are not afraid
of the virus
at all we've seen this again and again
and again the people who are forcing
business owners like dave morris to lose
their livelihoods and their businesses
and they're forcing everyone not to see
their family and their friends and
they're forcing everyone
to waste months and months and months of
their lives
do not fear the virus they just want you
to fear the virus but they don't
their behavior patently contradicts it
nancy pelosi not wearing masks violating
the salon orders
gavin newsom not wearing masks seeing
lots and lots of his friends
close contact indoor restaurant at a
fancy place with a michelin rating
on and chris cuomo the list goes on
there's a new one now
steve adler this is my favorite one
steve adler the mayor of austin
so he's in texas right but he's the
mayor of the bluest city in texas
and steve adler has a very important
message for everybody which is
you can't go outside you got to stay
home
we need to you know stay home if you can
do everything you can to try to keep the
numbers down
this is not the time to to relax not the
time
to relax unless you are like steve adler
who filmed and broadcast that video i
kid you not
from his vacation in cabo
he made it to that vacation by flying a
private jet
with friends of his very close contact
with those friends
many many many miles from home
eight family members and guests on that
private jet to
this foreign place well he tells you to
stay home he doesn't need to stay home
why would he need to stay home so you
need to stay home
because that will help public health
forget about private health no no one
who is
healthy is worried about this virus
because the survival rate is
extraordinarily high
but he is worried about the public
ramifications meaning the political
ramifications meaning
taking power enforcing his will
while he violates it himself are we
going to get more of this if joe biden
does ascend to the presidency
well joe biden has a plan for his first
hundred days and it's a simple plan
you have to wear your masks my
inclination
uh jake is in the first day i'm
inaugurated to say i'm going to ask the
public for 100 days
to mask just 100 days to mask not
forever
100 days and i think we'll see a
significant reduction
if we occur that that occurs with
vaccinations and masking
to drive down the numbers considerably
come on it's just 100 days
hey come on it's not a big deal come on
just put the donut on your head come on
just hop up and down on one foot it's
not a big what's the big deal
just do the thing that i'm arbitrarily
concocting
and that i've been telling you now for
months and months is only going to last
a few days longer just do it
and even though there have been multiple
studies that show that
the way that this particular uh practice
is put into effect
doesn't really do all that much for
people's individual health
just do it anyway what's the big deal
now joe biden is now saying 100 days
we were told the lockdowns were going to
be 15 days
and i'm beginning to think that democrat
days they're kind of like dog years you
know they're just
we're we here day and we think that
means 24 hours
but it's different the democrats are on
a different timeline so for instance
15 days to slow the spread is a year
turns out that's going to be about a
year so
if 15 days is one year then
100 days by my calculations is
six and two-thirds years so we will be
into what the second harris
administration
at that point and then i assume there
will be the third and the fourth and the
fifth
harris administrations after that
because there's not going to be any
reason
that we're going to elect republicans
because the democrats want to end the
filibuster and they want to add new
states
and they want to create a permanent
majority at the national level
there is some good news on this front
though on both the election front and
the covet front
a judge is now saying that l.a county
health officials need to justify the
lockdown
you'll remember just like this austin
mayer the la county supervisor said i'm
shutting down
restaurants it is not safe to go to
restaurants even outside
two hours later she goes to santa monica
and has dinner at a restaurant
because the rules don't apply to her so
this judge is now saying the l.a county
health officials
need to justify the lockdown if they
want a three-week ban on outdoor dining
that is going to put a lot of business
owners at a business friend of mine
works at a restaurant in la this
restaurant spent something like a
hundred thousand dollars
turning their their outdoor area into a
place where you can dine hundred
thousand dollars now down the drain
for what margins they were already going
to be losing money
now for what it's going to put them out
of business judge says
you need some evidence to justify it the
police
state you know the the the local
officials
have this police power during
emergencies
but it's not an a limitless police power
you need to justify these actions and
what what these
people are doing right now is not
justifiable at this point
after all that we have learned about the
virus and the lockdowns and the liars
who have pushed this nonsense on us
i think that people should disobey
every single lockdown rule
as much as humanly possible i understand
it's not possible to disobey the rules
all of the time
you can't get on an airplane for
instance unless you got at least a mask
sort of on is it right okay i understand
that
and by the way if people feel that they
want to
do something to protect themselves and
they have some
probably neurosis but maybe a legitimate
concern about it okay
yeah okay that's fine but the rules
themselves
you should disobey them all the time if
all of us disobey these stupid rules
then these sociopath politicians who do
not think the rules matter at all for
them and who do not fear the virus at
all they would have to stop
because they would be shown to be
powerless they'd be shown
to be totally impotent they would
give up very very important
thing we need to go out there we need to
be healthy
we need to go get some sunshine we need
to go back to living our lives
seeing one another again being social
looking at each other's smiles stop
muzzling our faces all the time we need
to go out there and be well
by the way if you are interested in
wellness you should check out for
hymns.com
which is all about men's wellness if you
need help with
ed hair loss or have a cold if you're
interested
in mental health or covid19 home tests
hymns is here for you through hymns you
can get a prescription medication
that treats ed real science real
solutions to
ed hymns makes it easy hims connects you
with a licensed
medical professional online who can
prescribe fda
approved prescription medication to
treat something that
a lot of men have and struggle with and
there is a way out of it
you get the same active ingredient as
that expensive little pill
but without the expensive price tag no
embarrassing conversations
no expensive appointments just answer a
few questions online about your medical
history
and a provider will confidently review
it if approved your medication is
shipped
directly to your door in discrete
packaging shipping is free
why live with this problem when the
solution can be so
so simple i know a lot of people they
just don't they don't want to talk about
it they don't
you know it's a problem that's sort of
some guys just feel uncomfortable with
well you can get a solution today try
hymns today
by starting out with a free online visit
go to for hims.com
michael for your free visit that is for
hims.com
michael f-o-r-h-i-m-s dot com
m-i-c-h-a-e-l
prescription products are subject to
medical provider approval and require an
online consultation with a medical
provider who will determine if a
prescription is appropriate
see website for full details and safety
information remember that is for
hims.com
michael speaking of
good rulings from judges not on the
covid front but on the
presidential race a georgia judge
has approved a forensic examination of
the voting machines
so there have been questions about these
voting machines
the theories about what could have
happened go all the way up to the level
that there's some international
conspiracy and the votes were changed
but some of the theories are also more
modest just that there were individual
issues with these voting machines
and those individual issues would be
enough to change possibly the election
in a state so for so long the media have
been saying no this is ridiculous no
there could be no problems with
electronic voting
no there's no way that they're connected
to the internet even though they
probably are connected to the internet
no it's not a big deal move on move on
certify the election well this judge
district judge timothy batten senior
issued the order
saying no do not reset the dominion
election systems
do not wipe the machines we need to have
a forensic
audit now what's going on in the
counting process and the recounting
process well georgia
also now has to rescan 12 000 ballots
the georgia republican party chairman
david shaffer said on wednesday night
fulton county is going to rescan
a whole 12 000 batch of ballots
because of quote unexplained technical
problems
unexplained technical problems uh fulton
county commissioner liz houseman
alerted david that fulton county is
redoing this this count uh republican
monitors have then been
uh sent out to the tabulation center but
david shaffer
in in the gop of georgia has been
sounding the alarm on this
for a month now or more
there were legitimate concerns
over fraud there is a lot of evidence
that there was fraud
in georgia twelve thousand votes being
reskinned what's the margin in georgia
right now separating biden and
trump twelve thousand yikes that's not
good
do we have any other evidence of fraud
yes we do some video footage from the
election centers came out yesterday
fulton county sent the poll watchers
home
at 10 30 p.m on election night they said
so you got to get out of here we're
gonna stop counting now so anyone trying
to make sure we don't
mess around with the ballots go home the
republican officials the poll watchers
generally go home
but a smaller group of election
officials stuck around
the counting center and they didn't just
stick around for 10 minutes and get
their coats they stuck around for hours
they stuck around for a minimum of two
hours we have this
on video they tabulated 3 000
ballots per hour per
voting machine and there were multiple
voting machines you can see people going
out underneath tables
wheeling out boxes ballots after we were
told
they were going to stop counting after
the poll watchers went home
this sort of thing is the fraud i'm not
saying it's even enough fraud
to swing the vote maybe it is maybe it
isn't sure
stinks to high heaven
but the mere act of doing this is the
fraud
huge questions in georgia 12 000 votes
separate the race
you got 3 000 votes per hour per machine
and multiple machines in just this one
place
goodness gracious how are we supposed to
have faith in our election system
especially in georgia which you may
recall i
figured it was on this show or in
another interview i did express
fears that there would be these kinds of
shenanigans in georgia
specifically in georgia before the
election
all of that means there is absolutely no
reason whatsoever
to concede the presidential race before
the legal process plays out not one
i am very very supportive of pursuing
every single
legal process to flip this race back to
president trump
however we also need to take a look at
what else is going on in georgia namely
this runoff election for
that we'll end up determining who
controls the u.s senate there is a
lawyer who i suppose is a pro-trump
lawyer lynn wood
who is down in georgia saying that
republicans should not vote
in the senate runoff where is kelly
loffler here
[Music]
where is david perdue you ought to be
standing right here
those two people want your vote then
they ought to tell you
what would get a special session of the
legislature now
do not be fooled twice this is georgia
we ain't
dumb we're not going to go vote on
january 5th and another machine made by
china
you're not going to fool georgians again
if kelly loffler wants your vote
if david perdue wants your vote they've
got to earn it
[Music]
they've got to demand publicly
repeatedly consistently
brian kemp call a special session of the
georgia legislature
and if they do not do it if kelly
loffler and david perdue
do not do it they have not earned your
vote
don't you give it to them okay i'll say
one nice thing about linwood before i
say
some not very nice things i i do like
that
when people go out and use political
leverage and they actually use it to
affect their political ends especially
if those are good political ends
i understand that and that's what he's
doing he's giving a stump speech and
saying we want a special session of the
legislature and we want
lawfuller and perdue to come out here
and take part in this lawful and purdue
probably are not going to do that
because they want to play it a little
safer because they've got to focus on
their races not the presidential race
so that's the disagreement and lynwood
is saying come on come out here and
defend trump
okay fair enough here are the other
issues
lynn wood is apparently a democrat
linwood has not voted in a gop primary
in 16 years
uh eric erickson just discovered that in
2008 lynnwood contributed 2 300 bucks to
barack obama
in the presidential cycle before that he
gave 250 bucks to john edwards another
democrat
uh wood voted in the abrams the stacey
abrams primary in 2018
uh and he did not vote in donald trump's
primary in 2016.
so okay maybe he had a change of heart
maybe he's totally on the
trump train now or he's totally
conservative or whatever could be the
case
however he is a democrat and that is
worth keeping in mind when you listen to
his political advice
the way that i see this being debated
right now among conservatives is you
have some people who are saying yes
absolutely that's right
support trump don't vote in georgia and
then you've got some other people in the
conservative movement
who are saying hey listen give up on
trump we should concede the race
but you do have to vote in georgia and
i i just don't understand why people are
not capable of doing two things at once
in politics
namely don't give up the presidential
race keep pursuing the legal process
on the presidential race don't concede
an inch until the constitutional process
has played out and
preserve control of the senate for the
republicans
is this because i have some special love
of david perdue and kelly laufler
no i don't i don't dislike them either
they're fine
they're republican senators it's not
really about them
well is it because i love mitch
mcconnell so much no i mean
mitch does a pretty good job you know he
gave us a lot of judges and
you know he's really good at just
screaming while holding automatic
weapons and just saying
sure hello to my little friend and all
that kind of thing i do like his
character
in politics but it's not it's not just
that
it's because i know what the democrats
are going to do if they get
a senate majority if democrats get a
senate majority especially if they get
the white house
they've promised to end the filibuster
that i think is almost guaranteed
they've promised to add another state to
the country
i'm not saying that's guaranteed because
that would be a big deal
but they would be totally on board for
it
and it would give them very likely a
permanent majority
and then they've threatened to pack the
court and you've got
guys like joe manchin he's basically the
last semi-moderate democrat in america
joe manchin says i will not pack the
court well okay i don't really give a
damn that you're not going to pack the
court
if you are going to give democrats a
permanent majority by adding a state to
the union
so what about we've already lost the
we've already lost the country at the
national level
so what do i care yeah add 10 million
judges to the court
we already don't have political resource
recourse
at the national level at that point so
you've got to pay attention to that too
why can't we do both why do why do we
how come either way this breaks out do
we have to behave like half democrats i
don't understand that
i don't i don't see any for the very
same reason that i see no reason to
concede this presidential election
i see no reason to be conciliatory here
and say let's give the
let's give the senate to the democrats
i understand the frustration and the
idea that it's a rigged system
but the way to guarantee that we're not
going to have any
justice in this is to throw our hands up
then you can't you can't blame it on
fraud they'll just say well you didn't
vote
that's what they'll point to that's what
the left will point to i understand the
frustration but we should not cut off
our nose
to spite our face we should try very
hard on the trump front
we should try very hard on the senate
front a biden administration with a
democratic senate would be ruinous even
just a biden administration would be
absolutely
terrible there are appointees that joe
biden
is looking at who
are modeling their education policies on
communist china our country is
is being confronted right now with
perils the likes of which we've never
seen before
as the great edmund burke put it all it
takes for evil to prevail is for good
people to do nothing
if you want to help preserve america
while we still can
then maybe you should consider joining
amac the association of mature american
citizens
the fastest growing conservative group
in america joining amac gives you access
to money-saving benefits
cutting-edge news and a great bi-monthly
magazine but more importantly amac
fights
for you a socialist storm is a bruin
if you care about our future then join
amac today over 2 million conservatives
have already joined amax stand
with amac by joining right now go to
amac
dot u s slash knowles canada w l e s
that is a
m a c dot u s forward slash
knowles the benefits of a mac membership
are great but the cause is even greater
join amac dot us
forward slash knowles to join with a lot
of other like-minded american citizens
who have accumulated wisdom who
understand
the perils that our country is facing
right now
and who want to stand up and stay free
and fight just like our friend over in
michigan said amac.us
knowles the uh
the biden education transition leader
you know joe biden because he's already
named himself the president-elect has
this transition team
and he gives speeches from the vaunted
office of the president-elect
so he has this transition leader
stanford university professor
linda darling hammond she's president of
the california state board of education
now heading the education transition
team she has praised
the chinese communist party's education
system
for its quote magical work
china you'll know has an education
system but probably what china is better
known for is it's a re-education system
it's foisting of ideology on people
of a radical ideology that
is uh creating our largest geopolitical
adversary
our biggest enemy abroad she says it's
magical right
if you get a joe biden presidency we are
going to see
a radical takeover of a radical
transformation of our institutions but
also you're going to see the u.s go much
easier on china
already people are downplaying china's
very evil
actions nike we talked about this
yesterday nike
is trying to let china keep using slave
labor
people even seem to forget that china
unleashed this stupid virus upon the
world
that gave politicians a pretext to
destroy our institutions upend our lives
destroy our livelihoods and take away
our civil rights
people forget that it was china actually
what the environmentalists say
is that this is the world healing do you
remember that meme
from months ago they say oh the virus
was just a
it was a reaction of mother nature and
to our
sins against the climate and now we're
all stuck in doors and weeds are growing
up on sidewalks and that's
oh that's nature healing the world is
going back to normal it was funny when
the riots came to los
angeles later on in the summer you had
korean business owners in k-town going
back to the rooftops with their
rifles like they did during the 1990s
riots and
that was another part of it they said ah
yes nature is healing
that the koreans are returning to the
rooftops we are the virus
well prince harry is spouting the same
environmentalist nonsense
prince harry is saying that quote
mother nature has sent us to our rooms
for bad behavior to really take a moment
and think about what we've done
he said this to water bear which i guess
is some environmental outlet
a reminder that prince harry pollutes
more than just about any other private
citizen
by a lot by a long shot that's actually
part of why he left the royal family
to follow whatever his wife wanted to do
is because he was getting a lot of
negative press
because he would say one thing about
environmentalism and then he would take
private jets
and live in houses that cost 14 million
dollars even as a private citizen
and obviously have a much larger impact
on the natural environment
than any of us do because for liberal
elites they do not need
to practice what they preach they don't
even need to pretend
to practice what they preach
aoc oh my gosh did she prove this aoc
has a shop and she sells merchandise
so at shop.ocasiocortez.com
aoc the socialist darling of america
is selling a tax the rich sweatshirt
for just about 60 bucks tax the rich
but you have to be rich to buy the shirt
and the people who support aoc tend to
be
pretty rich because she is not just a
representative
from new york in the federal government
she is in a way a priestess
of the fashionable liberal
policy that is taken for religion by a
great many people
other merch you can buy it's a new deal
a new green new deal mug
for 27 bucks you can get a drink water
and don't be racist t-shirt
okay for 27 bucks you can get a cancel
student
debt t-shirt for 27 bucks if you're
buying 27
t-shirts probably you don't have a lot
of student debt or you do and you're
just hoping that somebody will pay your
debts for you
you can buy an abolish ice hat
for 28 bucks and then i love this is my
favorite one
social economic racial justice
sweatshirt 65 bucks
that is magnificent daily wire actually
who i don't know who it was somebody on
our team came up with
this new daily wire sweatshirt that
they're selling and it says
insert woke slogan here or something to
that effect and
in the same font as aoc's and we're
selling it for cheaper than she was like
10 or 20 bucks cheaper so anyway you can
go over to dailywire.com right now
we're selling those to me that's a much
more beautiful uh
sweatshirt this is
a group of people who who are
foisting an ideology on the rest of us
that they do not believe themselves
whether it's aoc or whether it's the
politicians
with the lockdowns this is a cynical
strategy employed by
hypocrites and and a lot of politicians
throughout history
there's nothing new about that but we
have absolutely no obligation to go
along with that
the the politicians voicing these
mandates on us have made it clear
they don't believe it they are not
living in fear of the virus remember
president trump came and said don't live
in fear of the virus
and the entire liberal establishment
came out and said yes you should
be afraid curl up in your room don't see
your family
stay home let us destroy the economy and
take away your civil rights
i don't think there was much of an
argument to do that even if the virus
were as bad as everyone was saying it is
even if it were as deadly and it's
obviously
not the the survival rates are much much
much
much higher than the liberal elites have
been letting on to people
but if it were if it were legitimate
maybe there's some argument you know in
some crazy extreme circumstances
but there isn't an argument now these
people
don't believe it you should stop heeding
these stupid lockdowns you should stop
keeping your business closed you should
stop wearing that stupid mask in public
all the time
you should if you want to behave with
prudence and responsibility
then yeah exercise your faculties of
prudence and you know if you
if you really think that putting on the
cloth mask is going to help you in
certain narrow circumstances okay fine
whatever
but as a public matter these lockdowns
are completely preposterous
you should disobey them all the time as
much as humanly possible
you should wake up stand up and be free
one thing when i think about what it
means to be an american
i think it means exercising our
wonderful
political traditions i think it means
having some confidence
i think it means having a healthy love
of freedom not in the idea of
licentiousness or some radical
individualism but freedom and
really in the american context that we
have been granted by our forebears and
wonderful institutions they brought
and i think it means eating a lot of
delicious food whenever we want that's
why i love my power air fryer
you know i'm very very very excited to
talk about the power
xl air fryer grill
you can replace eight kitchen appliances
with the power xl
it's an air fryer a grill a rotisserie
confection oven pizza oven griddle deep
fryer toaster oven all in one
the power xl cooks with hot air not
oil so you can cook healthier with up to
70 percent fewer calories
uh you can cook for the entire family
it fits over four times more food than a
traditional air fryer and cooks
much faster to save you time i used my
delicious air fryer last night
we made chicken fingers and sweet potato
french fries
it was absolutely fabulous we loved it
just me and sweet little atleast and a
bunch of very delicious food
i got a ton of accessories nonstick
grill plate crisper tray baking pan dip
drip tray
oven rack they are all dishwasher safe
so cleanup is super easy it is almost as
though
these guys sat down and thought about
all the problems with cooking appliances
and decided to start solving them that
is why this is the number one brand of
air fryers in the u.s
the power xl air fryer comes with a
90-day money-back guarantee
right now they have an exclusive offer
just for the holiday season if you go to
trypowerxl.com
use promo code knollscannerwles you will
receive 10 off plus free shipping and a
free cookbook go to
t-r-y-p-o-w-e-r-x-l-com
use promo code nolescannerwles one last
time
for this holiday deal it's
tripowerxl.com use code knowledge can
you wlis
also head on over at dailywire.com you
can get our christmas ornaments and have
all your
all your favorite daily wire hosts
hanging from your tree they're very fun
and they were made by the way they were
designed by a daily wire
all access elite member text christmas
to 83 400
to get your tree decorated we'll be
right back with the mailbag
i'm running late on the mailbag as usual
so we will fly
through it first question from veronica
okay mike let's settle the porn question
i see so many people in the chat saying
porn should be banned and this is a very
silly view that i'd like to address
my main argument is that it does no good
to ban porn if mainstream movies and tv
are
i'm pornographic to obviously disagree
with you here veronica i think but let's
keep going
would you agree that porn itself is not
as much of a problem as the
mainstreaming of it
it is one thing for people to look at
porn in shame and secret it is another
for people to openly watch
graphic sex on tv with friends and
family acting like it's normal
i think the latter is worse for our
culture than the former and another haze
code
would do us more good than a porn ban
ideally it would be better if nobody
looked at or participated in porn but we
don't live in candyland we live in
reality we need real world solutions
what are your thoughts
thanks for your time and so happy you
have a friday show now thank you
veronica i appreciate it
you make a very good point here i
disagree with your
top line point but i agree with all the
individual points you're making
what you're saying is the culture is so
pornographic you know we have game of
thrones or whatever
and uh and things that are actually much
more pornographic even than that
and so it doesn't matter if you've got
some naughty websites on the internet
because if the culture is going to be so
licentious then it doesn't matter anyway
i don't think that's true i think
i think it it can be the case that these
are all
problems and if you can fix one of those
problems that would be a very good thing
i do think they're different in kind
also i just think
the ubiquity and total
deregulation just about of high speed
porn everywhere you know on any kid who
has a cell phone
is accessing this all the time that that
is a big problem and you
you can regulate it now i do agree with
you i think an outright ban is probably
impossible and i actually there are
arguments from uh
from saint augustine and st thomas
aquinas
of all people who were in a way
defending legal prostitution
not because it's okay to go to
prostitutes or i guess supposed to look
at porn
but just because as you say we don't
live in candy land
there are this is the way societies have
always existed there's probably some
kind of reason for that if you can
contain the problem
then that might be a more practical and
prudent solution than an outright ban
which might be impracticable
and might have outside effects i'm fine
with that i i think that's okay i think
it's important for conservatives
to be realistic about how to work in the
world but what i would favor
if you're saying that the two options
here are be totally fine with
high-speed porn and go for an outright
ban
what i'm saying is why don't we just
heavily regulate porn there's no
there's no conservative argument against
that
we we already have laws against
obscenity before the internet we had
strict regulations on porn everywhere in
the country
so why don't we just apply that to the
internet as well i am totally fine with
that
i think this is a major problem it's a
it's a obviously a moral problem
it's also a public health problem to use
the fashionable phrase
when you've got kids who get hooked on
this stuff from a very young age which
is
in this day and age it's basically every
young man then they're going to have
lots of problems in the future personal
problems and
political problems public problems
because you've got this
vice that that spreads like wildfire
you don't need to be totally puritanical
to say this is a problem it doesn't
benefit
anybody and we've got to try to fix that
problem
it doesn't sound perfectly ideologically
pure but i think that's the prudent
solution
and prudence is not just a virtue
generally
but a virtue that conservatives have
long understood and the ones who don't
understand that now need to get on the
program
from michael hey michael since you're a
guitar player who do you think is the
greatest guitar player of all time
i've heard many people speculate it
could be jimi hendrix angus young
eddie van halen eric clapton just
wondering what your thoughts were
on this subject thanks django reinhardt
no doubt no question from leo hey
michael came for ben stayed for nols
could you expand on the fraud
allegations the numbers for biden
seemed too unlikely to be true and some
of the voter turnouts are just through
the roof
as the last host not to concede i would
like your input great to have you five
days a week thank you very much
i i agree i have lots of skepticism
about this election very specific places
and we've talked about it on the show a
fair bit the brilliant thing that the
democrats did in this election
is by completely changing the way that
the election
is conducted for the first time in
america having widespread unsolicited
mail-in votes
which i think are absolutely
illegitimate and in some places are
explicitly unconstitutional
like in pennsylvania but by doing that
you make it you make it such that you
can't compare the turnout in this
election to previous elections
is what's turned out it's supposed to be
what 72 million for trump and
uh 7 zillion for joe biden or something
at this point they're going to keep
counting those votes in georgia
well it actually is possible whatever
they say 72 and 80 or whatever
million votes it is possible even though
those numbers are much higher than last
time
you've got a completely different system
so if last time you basically had to
show up to the polls to vote
and this time you can do it from your
couch and everybody and their cousin
gets a ballot mailed directly to them
whether they request it or not well now
we have
nothing to compare it to it's completely
apples and oranges and i suspect that's
why
the democrats pushed for that system
because if there were shenanigans then
you would have no frame of reference
it's very dispiriting
i'm pleased to see that that the georgia
judges at least are starting to take
this seriously
i think we need to keep fighting from
tammy people keep saying if biden wins
the election then there will be a red
tsunami in 2022 for congress
if biden pulls this off how could we
ever have faith in the voting system
again yeah
i think that's a fair question people
aren't going to have a ton of faith
i will say there is fraud in every
single election so the idea that there
were some fraudulent votes this time
it's not just a theory that's guaranteed
we know we know that for a fact
the question is was the fraud widespread
enough
to to throw the election
maybe it was maybe it isn't you know the
most extreme theories of fraud here
involve you know the deep state and the
cia or whatever okay
you don't need that you know i don't
know i haven't
spoken with langley in quite some time
but i i i don't
know i haven't seen a ton of evidence
that that happened maybe it did maybe it
didn't
what i what i'm saying is put those
extreme
fanciful theories aside just look at
what's right in front of you i think
sometimes the extreme theories are used
to distract us from what's right in
front of us
widespread unsolicited mail-in ballots
are intrinsically vulnerable to fraud
the new york times admitted this in
2012.
i don't need theories about the cia to
to know
with with certainty that this is a bad
election system that is open to fraud
that even the liberals agreed with us on
eight years ago how do we have faith in
that we've got to fight
the unsolicited mail-in ballots and i
fear that the democrats
have have brought them and they're here
to stay the other issue is
if if the democrats do get a unified
government
for the next two years and the
filibuster at puerto rico
there you go there's your permanent
majority a lot to be fighting for right
now from aruna
dear dr covfefe as a physicist i can
confirm that your description of
schrodinger's cat
thought experiment accurately
represented the concept of quantum
superposition
to a level that i would not expect from
a yale history major thank you very much
i appreciate it
i'm i'm really good at following the
wikipedia trails all the way down so i
can at least learn the phrases
dare i say there was more scientific
truth in your explanation
than there is peacefulness at a mostly
peaceful protest
if president-elect trump and
president-elect biden are indeed
two eigenstates of the same quantum
system can you give us a hint as to
which state has a higher energy well i i
do know
and i say this with all of my scientific
expertise that president trump has
dragon energy
and so because he has dr he and kanye
west both have dragon energy because
of that fact i think the winner has to
ha of that particular question has to go
to trump
from jeffrey to my favorite maddow
impersonator or is she impersonating you
and purveyor of kuffe recently there has
been a lot of visibility with the pope
and various other leaders in the
catholic church espousing or at least
tolerating views
that are directly contrary to the word
of god and the catechism
for example the ordaining of a
transgender priest in february
uh hold on i've got to pause here that
did not happen that is fake news
i i looked up this story when it started
floating around
the internet uh there's some heretical
fake catholic sect of priestesses or
something that
pretends that they're priests and they
ordained ordained quote unquote
some person of unknown sex or sexual
identity but
that's not real the catholic church
hasn't has not ordained a transgender
priest
but there are problems as you say
offering communion to abortionists like
joe biden which which cardinals have
said they'll do
and in fact elevating one who has done
so
pope francis supporting blm the grammar
is a little
confusing there but uh there there are
plenty of criticisms that people have
made of pope francis my question is this
why should faithful christians do when
church leadership is acting in such an
unchristian way
is there a process to impeach a bishop
or hire what will they do if they start
feeling real pressure from within the
congregations
at what point should it be said that the
catholic church is not acting with god's
authority
and the remnant should go to find or
plant the truly faithful assembly well
you know as a catholic
i think that there will never be a time
when when christ abandons his
church and that the church is particular
and it's incarnational
and it has a real line and thread that
goes all the way back to the beginning
uh so that's that is the catholic
perspective and there
so it actually may it allows you to rest
easy a little bit because
you don't have to constantly be worrying
about okay is it is this new
denomination or is this new denomination
or is this the one or you know
so uh it but it doesn't relieve the
frustration when the episcopacy
does things that are very stupid and
sometimes heretical and there we've look
we've had
heretics who have been cardinals or
popes even
in the history of the church there
there is a uh a great line from hillary
bellock one of the great catholic
writers
and he said that as a catholic it is
a matter of faith for him that he has to
believe that the catholic church is the
church instituted by christ with
all this divine protection but a piece
of evidence that it's the real church
for for non-believers
is that no other organization conducted
with such
navish imbecility would have lasted a
fortnight much less
2000 years and that that is sort of my
view
when bishops or cardinals or popes do
stupid things which is
if not frequent it happens you know a
fair bit
we have to remember that the these are
human beings and that the pope
is not infallible except when he is
infallibility is invoked what twice in
the history of the church
so he can say plenty of fallible things
and popes and bishops have have done
that before
one thing the faithful laity can do
though is withhold their money
give your money to your parish keep the
lights on you know keep keep the
church services going and the masses
going and all that
but when the bishops have their pet
projects and things like that
i don't give to those anymore i don't
think the bishops have
earned the credibility for to ask us to
give to those things over the past few
years and so i don't give to those and i
think
that the more that the bishops have idol
pachamama idols and all sorts of
madness the less that we're going to
give and that's one way that we can
get our point across because because
money talks
in a lot of aspects of life one more
question from cheryl asking you a
question from the lone star state so
proud to live in a red state i want to
remain practical and believe
that all covid restrictions will be
removed once the vaccine is available to
the public
slightly concerned though that carrying
papers is proof of getting a vaccine
could be possible for america do you
believe that america's future will
require people to scan papers to enter
stores or go to public events
like concert it's possible that
americans will just have to wear masks
forever instead of showing proof of a
vaccine
absolutely love your show keep up the
good work thank you very much this is
already being introduced in wales it's
already being introduced in the united
kingdom
and i'm sure even though america
prefers to go our own way sometimes and
not like europe or not even like the uk
i'm sure some of the left-wing
politicians will will try to
push that through here i won't do it
when i do
have to wear the mask in certain cases
in public i almost always have my nose
poking out as a
not-so-subtle protest um and then most
of the time i don't even
have it on i don't pay attention to
these stupid things i'm not going to
carry around papers so that i can do
engage in commerce or anything like that
i'm just going to ignore it and maybe
there will be consequences to that maybe
we deal with those consequences
but i'm going to ignore those those
ridiculous lockdown rules and i think
that you should too
that is our show wake up
stand up be free i'm michael knowles
this is the mike and all show see monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20.
you know the matt walsh show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll give it a listen
you